bosse bosse bosse c'est des
personnages supprimés mon pote oui c'est un peu
de caractère il aimait les personnages
parfois on les aime tellement on
s'accroche à quoi pendant longtemps puis on les jette
ouais et ces gars ils n'ont pas fait la
coupe ils  n'a pas fait la coupe, mais ne vous inquiétez pas,
ils vont bien, ils se
promènent juste dans Zootopia quelque part ouais
tu es allé petit Dickens, elle avait
différents emplois et a fait différentes
apparitions à un moment donné, c'était juste une
vieille chèvre hurlante ouais parfois elle
s'évanouirait, elle s'évanouirait, elle était une
vieille chèvre évanouie, mais ensuite elle est revenue en
tant que femme de ménage. Swinton était notre
méchant dans la version précédente de l'
histoire et nous l'avons fait parce que les cochons sont
des animaux très intelligents et nous pensions
qu'ils seraient très  intéressant faire un
cochon intelligent le méchant dans le film à la
fois intelligent et savoureux est toujours un cochon
il y a un mouton dans le film appelé
Willy qui faisait toutes sortes de
choses néfastes et avez-vous vu le
film final que vous connaissez t  chapeau elle a continué
à faire des trucs néfastes dans Zootopia mais
cette fois il cachait son identité
avec un corset et il
s'attacherait et il se ferait très maigre
et s'envelopperait dans un pardessus et
mettrait un déguisement de loup donc il était un mouton  dans
des vêtements de loup
ah